so in the ask our leaders born I know
what they're not really asking are they
born what they're really asking is are
there some people when they're born they
got it getting started is absolutely the
key to life dreams are free but the
journey isn't
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from leadership guru John
Maxwell and my take on his top ten rule
to success vol 2 rule number five is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always as you're listening if something
really resonates with you there's a
message that really holds true to you
please leave it down the comments below
and put it in quotes so that other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy
if I could just literally come off the
station and I could get real close to
you and we can have kind of like a
one-on-one conversation there are two
questions that I would ask you and the
two questions I'm about to ask you will
really determine how successful you're
going to be in this business without any
question these are the two questions
it's not like there's three or there's
four or they're seven there's two okay
just trust me on this I'm an old man I
know this I've been around the block a
few times and there are two questions
that if you're going to answer in a
positive way about yourself you're going
to be very successful and if you really
cannot answer that in a positive way to
be honest with you you're not going to
be near successful as you would like to
be the first question is very simple
what are you doing to develop yourself
and if you say by gosh Jenna I'll tell
you right now I'm doing a lot to develop
myself I I mean I've got a personal
growth plan and and I'm intentional in
this and I'm doing this on a daily deal
if you could say that to me that I'd say
hey we're in good shape here we're in
good shape because that's the key
what are you doing to develop yourself
and by the way the reason that's pursed
is not because you want to be selfish
it's kind of like almost a selfish
question versus well why do I start with
myself the reason you start with
yourself is because you cannot give what
you do not have so you better start with
yourself because if you're leading
others and have nothing to give them
nothing to share with them nothing to
teach them then I can promise you you'll
never be what you want to be as a leader
and I can promise you that after 40
years of personal growth the secret of
any success if I've had any success at
all the secret of that success has been
personal growth in my life
and growth this has literally placed me
where I am so so what are you doing to
develop yourself it's a huge question
and the 15 laws overly of the 15 laws a
personal growth basically these laws are
all about developing yourself in
developing the second question what are
you doing to develop others you see on
the first question your foundational for
you
future the second question is all about
compounding multiplication that's where
you build a huge business when you know
how to develop other people passion
often is linked with purpose what I love
to do is often what I should do we have
been created within us the capacity to
have things that we enjoy greatly and a
lot of times there is a definite
relationship between what I am in love
with and what I should be doing we are
created and wired in such a way that
that pie shouldn't purpose many times
comes together and passion is the great
energizer once you have passion you have
energy once you find your passion you
find your purpose
there is something energetic about it
you have never known a person who is
passionate that lacked energy we talk
about high energy people we talk about
low energy people there's no such thing
is like low energy people or high energy
people if you have high energy you have
passion if you have low energy you don't
have any passion you know some people
they're they're already dead they
haven't made it official yet
if you just look at I just want to walk
around and do the committal let them
watch and observe the whole process but
passion gives us a great amount of
energy and when we have that patient
there's something about how we love what
we're doing and we enjoy what we're
doing and passion energizes us a person
with passion always stands out the world
is so full of apathy it's so full of
average it's so full of whatever but
once you have passion and once you have
a sense of energy in your life it just
sets you apart it distinguishes you it
already gives you what I would call a
head start in successive life so when I
ask our leaders born I know what they're
not really asking are they born what
they're really asking is are there some
people when they're born they got it and
some of you when they're born they don't
got it if you got it you go to the
frontline if you don't got it you go to
the backline that's what they're asking
and I've got great news for you and I do
believe I have no question about it that
there are some people that are born with
what I call leadership leanings no doubt
about that just like some people are
born with kind of a musical lean no
doubt but the great news is because I've
done this for so long and I've done this
with so many over such a long period of
time in every country of the world what
I know is you can learn to lead you can
learn till you can you can learn to be a
better view than you are right now you
can you can grow as a leader if I'm a
five as a leader that means my
organization will be what talk to me
a core okay here we go because the lid
the leadership lid won't allow it to go
higher so how do I grow my organization
this is very simple folks I've got to
raise my lid don't I I've got to get
this lid up and because I can become a
better leader I can raise my lid through
so I can go from a five to a six go
seven to eight to a nine
now disorganisation is a four with that
leadership lid starts going up that
organization goes from a 4 to 5 to a 6
to 7 to an age you see your organization
will grow to the size of your leadership
ability now if I were where you are and
I was listening to what I just said
and I was taking notes somewhere on my
notes or somewhere on my iPad I'd be
putting a star right here I'd be put in
a rocketship I would be putting a sign
that says do not miss this because your
ability to lead will determine how
successful you'll be in this house
without any question the best leaders
will build the biggest business the
whole concept the whole idea that you
can learn to lead and if you learn to
lead in the better you learn to lead the
more successful you can become and the
greater your business this is an
absolute fact it's not a theory it's not
a thought it's not an idea it's not a
principle it's a fact and though all the
lid says the better you learn to lead
the higher you lift that lid the greater
your business can become now that's the
law the lid I brought something with me
today that's very special it's a kit and
and I'm just so pleased to have this
because this kid is very important to me
now it cost me seven hundred ninety nine
dollars and I got this kit I got this
kit back I got this kit back in nineteen
in the 1970s okay and and this was my
first personal growth
it's a you know dynamics of personal
growth setting by palmyre personal
success planner and and I'm so excited
cost $79 I they have to understand I
made about eight hundred dollars a month
so get the picture it took me six months
to buy this kit I saved up we didn't
have credit cards back then and I just I
just saved up
and worked hard and it took me six
months before I had enough cash to buy
this kit and I was so I was so excited
when I got it and uh
enemyís open it all up and this is just
amazing I just it had I mean you'll just
see some things here they're just crack
yep it had for some of young people
you've never seen this before
[Applause]
they're called cassette tapes now I
remember taking the first cassette tape
out put it on my little player opening
this up oh my gosh this was so wonderful
that wasn't they had I mean they had
page-by-page plans this and I mean look
at the plans and listen to the tapes and
go through the plans this is the tape
good plans mr. taine this is my first
growth experience and the ROI on this
$799 can it's worth millions of dollars
to me yet you heard me right millions of
dollars and experiences that a lifetime
of growth and what's interesting is now
here's what I want you to hear the value
of this kit the content was good but
that wasn't the value the content was
good but but was I look back now I say
what made this so special what made this
so special is very simple this is the
kit that got me started
hear me out the value of what you do for
people is not so much what you give to
them as much as it challenges them to
get started getting started
is absolutely the key to life and by the
time I finish going through this
personal growth kit by the time that was
all finished
I I had six months of day-in day-out
personal growth and what it is it
developed a habit in my life and by the
time I finished with that kit now I'm
used to I'm used to spending time every
day in personal growth it got me started
I mean this is this is worth this whole
lesson if you could just get this the
reason I'm so passionate about personal
growth is personal growth keeps me
prepared in other words if I'm
continually growing I continue to
develop it myself and I'm continually
learning and I'm continually doing new
things and and going to another step
higher can I tell you what that is that
that constant growth is the preparation
for the opportunity so when the
opportunity comes is here's a way you
don't go into an opportunity you grow
into an opportunity and so I'm packed
about personal growth because for that
person who says while I had an
opportunity I wasn't ready if you're
growing you're always ready because
after I intentionally started growing I
made a commitment to grow as a leader I
started writing I became an author I
developed growth resources for other
people I found in my first company I
began training conferences everything I
can think of that has ever been good in
my life was a result of the fact that I
started personal growth in my life I got
started and guess what when I got
started let me tell you what I didn't
have I didn't have experience I didn't
have knowledge I did not have a model I
did not have a mentor I did not have a
plan I did not have a fellow traveler I
did not have resources I did not have
money I did not have a growth
environment but I got started you don't
stop or not start because of what you
don't have you don't start because you
don't realize yet
that the fruit of everything good in
life begins with the challenge
there's nothing easy in life worthwhile
in life everything is a pill that's
worthwhile and it's not going to come to
you and it's not going to fall in your
lap and it's not going to be something
that oh my gosh
it just was so simple it's always going
to be difficult
the rule of 5 is the most life-changing
concept for focusing on success that I
have ever taught that I've ever lived so
I'm just going to drop it on you just
enough to help you understand the five
concept to help you understand the five
things you need to do to lift your
leadership lid the rule of five just
simply says if you have a tree in your
backyard that you want to cut down and
you have an axe if every day you pick up
that axe and you go to that tree and you
swing five times with that axe to hit
that tree put the axe down the next day
you go out pick up the axe swing five
times at the tree put the X ten the next
day you go out pick up the axe and five
more times you swing at that tree five
times every day you pick up the axe and
only five not 15 not 15 not five hundred
five if you swing five times a day at
that tree with that axe
every day let me ask you a question what
eventually is going to have that tree
that tree is going to know there's no
question about that isn't there's it
easy now
is you don't have to sit around the
table and kind of say do you think it
will
let's hold hands and sing Kumbaya and
who if you swing five times a day at
that tree every day that tree will fall
in story now if it's a big tree it may
take a couple years if it's a little
tree in your backyard I don't know maybe
maybe in a month you could knock that
baby died I don't decieve now now the
size of the tree will determine how long
it takes for it to fall but that's not
weird amazing here what we're teaching
here is if you swing five times a day at
that tree every day the tree will fall
now that's the rule five the rule of
five says find your tree what's your
goal in life what's your purpose what do
you want to accomplish well you want to
knock down where's your axe
what are your tools what what is it that
you're going to use to effectively go
after that goal five times a day what
are you what is it because whatever that
is whatever that is if you use it five
times a day every day you'll be highly
successful for example I write books so
let me just put that in writing for a
moment I arrived I've written 73 books
Jason that was nice introduction it's 22
million not 19
[Music]
but what's two or three million
give a little take a little little here
a little there people say John huh how
have you written 73 books oh thank you
for asking the rule of five you see
there are five things I do every day
that allows me to write that many books
it's not magic it's not that I'm
brilliant it's just that I know the rule
of five the rule of five you see every
day I read every day I file every day I
think every day I ask questions and
every day I write every day I do this
five things every day every day I read
every day I I file every day I think
everything I ask questions every day I
write every day I read every day I think
every day a file over the I ask
questions over there right every day I
think every day I read their to ask
questions every day a file over there
right every day I write every day I read
every think every day our file every day
I ask questions just like different
orders but every day doesn't matter
whether you swing the axe left hand
right hand it just got hit the tree
every day I read file playing gasps
questions write read think file ask
questions write three thing file ask
questions right you say now John what do
you mean by every day
this is where it gets a little long
sometimes what I mean by everyday is
every day now that you say doubt now
Olivia when you say every day do you
mean you do you do that on Sunday
every Sunday I read the file that's
questions right do you do that on your
birthday every birthday guess what every
birthday I read think file ask questions
right do you do that on Christmas guess
what I do every Christmas every
Christmas I really think wow my special
kids right do you do this when you're
not feeling well can I hear what I'm not
feeling well but I'm not feeling well
guess what I do every day every day I
refer feel well I'm not feeling I think
right ask questions do all those things
every day you say every day at the age
of 17 I started filing I'd never missed
a day I don't have a hundred quotes I
don't have a thousand coats
I have tens of thousands of quote I
don't have a hundred stories I don't
have a thousand stories I have 10,000
stories where did you get all the
stories where'd you get all this coach
was a very tell you something
guess want to do everyday Cece we
overestimate what we can do in a day and
we underestimate what we could do in
several days and you got to understand
you got to understand the secret of
success is not the fact that hey I
didn't say pain some days I get up and I
write for 12 hours and that's it no no
no no no I didn't say it right although
I write all day I just I read oh they
didn't say I think oh they didn't ask
questions all day I just said every day
every day you see doing a little bit
every day is a lot more important than
doing a lot some day and most people
live in some day well I'll tell you what
I think I'll get to that you know what I
think I'll try that you know what I
believe I got now where's the key you
got to figure out what the five are it
took me seven years to find my five her
writing is nature you're slow
I am it won't take you seven years but
it'll take you a long period of time I
can get the first two quickly but the
third the fourth the fifth it took me
four years to get the last one I can
remember as a parent as my children got
to a certain age and where they look to
me for influence I could remember very
well when I saw the beginning to go to
their friends and that's where their
influence began and that's where their
influence began to increase as a parent
that got a little scary for me because I
could I could see I was having a little
less influence than the French were
having a little bit more well my parents
were very wise my parents understood
that who my friends were was determined
who I was going to become birds of a
feather flock together and in their
wisdom they decided that they wanted to
know my friends and they wanted to see
my friends so therefore they provided a
lot of wonderful things in her home so
we would have our friends at our house
so that my parents could observe and
watch the kind of kids I ran around with
and what I learned as a kid growing up
is very simple there are some friends
that were positive for me and there were
some friends that were negative for me
and my determination of which friends I
was going to let influence me basically
determine whether I was going to have a
positive or a negative life fortunately
because of good parental advice and
guidance
I chose good friends which really did
make a difference because you see
friends are wonderful they give a
support they give a strength
they're either though a real asset or
real liability so I would just want to
encourage you choose your friends wisely
you don't need a lot but you need some
good ones every leader I have ever known
had a dream had a vision in fact I would
say to you if you're not seeing what
could be and what you would like to have
I would say you probably are not a
leader but what I've discovered about
dreams is this dreams are free but the
journey isn't
and so leaders go beyond just having a
dream they go beyond having a wish list
sitting around a table and kind of
hoping something might come to pass they
understand that if they have a dream if
there are a dreamer they have to pursue
that they have to take the journey the
dreams free the journey isn't and what
leaders find is that when they go forth
through that dream they continually have
to pay that price they continually have
to realize that they make down payments
on the dream they have but there's one
thing else I would like to say all
leaders realize that whatever they pay
it's worth the price because dreams for
them do come true I was sitting at a
round table with executives one day and
a person that is highly successful I
could tell was a little discouraged he
said John I've hit every goal of mine
and now I basically have lost my
motivation and my passion and I looked
at him I called him by name I'll say Don
that wasn't his name so Don ah the
problem is you've been goal oriented
instead of growth oriented you see if
you and I are just goal oriented when we
hit our goals it's kind of like Eureka
we've arrived we celebrate have a party
but then all of a sudden there's an
emptiness like okay I did it but if
you're growth-oriented and establish
goals within your growth oriented
journey you hit those goals which I look
at say hey this is just another step
towards my total growth and I've never
known a person who said John I've grown
as big as I could ever grow and I know
as much as I can ever know and so
therefore I have nothing to accomplish
you see if you're going oriented you hit
your goal and then be a little empty but
if your growth oriented you'll never hit
that goal just keep growing you and I
both know that God's gift to us is our
potential and our gift back to him is
what we do with our potential perhaps
the greatest insult that we can ever
give to our Creator is to be a slacker
to somehow have these gifts and have
these opportunities
have this potential and do nothing with
it I would suggest today that you
believe in yourself as much as God
believes in you he created you for
greatness now that's how he created you
you determine how great you become he
has already given you the potential he's
already given you the opportunity your
response either seize the moment in the
day and become all that you possibly can
be or slack in the moment and basically
rest and just let things come to you I
encourage you on a minute with Maxwell
take the potential that you have been
given as a gift and the way to say
thanks to that gift is by giving your
life your very best and the word that
came to my heart this year that I think
God wants me to focus on in 2015 is the
word intentional he wants me to be
intentional he wants me to maybe more
than ever before in my life really focus
on some things that are important and
and and live a life every day not a day
that kind of where I try to accept my
day but but a day where I lead my day
where a day where I focus on making sure
that I really really put my
intentionality where it needs to be we
all heard the expression all's well that
ends well I'm here to tell you all's
well that begins well and this is the
first of the year and for many of you
this is this is your chance this is your
shot this is your moment this is your
time this is your opportunity all of you
that are watching online the different
campuses they start this is your
opportunity this is your time this is
your moment this is your place for you
to really begin to live an intentional
life
thank you guys so much for watching I
really hope you enjoyed this video if
there's someone you like me to profile
in the next top ten
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what was your favorite message
from this video what did you learn from
this video that you're going to
immediately apply somehow in your life
or in your business please leave it down
the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout-out to Jane
Cassell Jane thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and post in that awesome tweet I
really appreciate the support and I'm so
glad that you're enjoying the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
people that are knowledgeable about
habits say that it takes 30 days for a
habit to become a habit in other words
you and I can't in one or two days
develop a habit it takes a long time in
fact I am prone to think it takes a
little longer than 30 days now habits
can be good and habits can be bad and so
over a period of time you can either be
developing habits that are going to help
you can be developing habits that are
going to hurt you people that grow
develop habits that help them the great
value of a good habit is you don't have
to think about it that's why it's a
habit in other words once you begin to
over days and times and periods begin to
practice something that's good after
well it becomes automatic to you it
becomes who you are in fact I always say
I'll tell people practice a good habit
long enough to make it yours and once
it's yours now it's automatic everyday
you'll do what you should do first or
this week about the lady who bought a
parent of the store and she was kind of
lonely since she wanted a parent to kind
of take home to talk to us has took the
pair at home and set there and you know
the parrot in the cage and parrot didn't
say a word next issue went Distortion
parent didn't honk both of those in the
management store said well you know
maybe you need to get a ladder for the
cage because parrots like to climb and
then get exercise and so she's got a
ladder and putting the cage and set
there what's the parrot didn't talk so
the next station with next door says you
know I got the ladder doesn't talk he
says you probably need a swing parents
parents like to swing and just kind of
go back and forth a little bit put some
in a good mood scoffs when close the
cage went back home you know sit there
and once the parrot fairy didn't talk
come back to store next action is got
the swing got the ladder a parrot still
doesn't talk said we you need a mirror
paradise look at himself and get a
mirror in there and that that a Hobson's
meant got a mirror put it in there
encouraged us to look at herself and
swaying climb she came back to manager
the next day so the parent died she's a
parent died oh how terrible he said that
the parents say anything before he died
yeah said the parent said don't they
sell food down there
I'm hungry I'm hungry I know I'll kind
people in their spiritual life they got
ladders they got mirrors they got swings
they got stuff and they don't understand
they don't understand fit less is more
than what you've got to do is go put a
simple go for this go for the true go go
for the food for your own soul